are you able to talk about what's going  on with you on Twitter yeah so I uh when  I got banned in 2021 early 2021  um I got this really mysterious phone  call from someone they're like hey hit  me up on Signal and I'm like okay and  they're like you're on a list and I'm  like yeah I assume I'm on all the lists  and uh like no no like you're on like a  government list like Code Orange you're  you're talking too much about election  stuff and I'm like okay well I mean you  know 81 million my my ass I'm gonna keep  talking about it and uh sure enough  couple weeks later I got I got banned  for election misinformation in February  2021. and then Judicial Watch came out  with the results of a foia request that  showed that the state of California was  emailing Twitter saying DC Drano is  spreading election misinformation I am a  licensed attorney in the state of  California and they shut down my free  speech